hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich habe heute ein richtig
leckeres rezept für euch denn ich mache
heute schoko cookies und ich habe lange
nach einem perfekten rezept gesucht ich
habe ganz viele rezepte ausprobiert und
ich finde das sind jetzt die besten
cookies die hier gemacht habe diese
nämlich richtig schön schokoladig und
innen sind sie so ein bisschen feucht
also nicht trocken und außen knusprig
also der perfekte kopie eben und ich
zeige euch einfach mal die zutaten das
beste an dem rezept ist wir brauchen
keine küchenmaschine das geht alles
einfach mitten im löffel und wir
brauchen auch gar nicht so viel zutaten
als ich brauche für das rezept 150 gramm
puderzucker 30 gramm kakaopulver daneben
bietet bei kakao und keinen körper 50
gramm mehl
ihr könnt hier auch glutenfreies mail
benutzen ich habe hier 50 gramm
schokolade das ist jetzt satt
bitterschokolade die habe ich bereits
fein gehackt hier habe ich 50 gramm
mandeln die sind auch gehackt könnte
auch andere nüsse oder sonst irgendwas
nehmen
hier habe ich noch 50 gramm schokolade
und zwar ist es eine back feste
schokolade also die behält beim backen
reform dann brauche ich ein bisschen
vanille aroma ich habe sie ihren mann in
der extrakt zwei eiweiß und eine prise
salz und das rezept geht auch ziemlich
schnell
ich brauche wirklich gar nicht so viel
werkzeug dafür das heißt jeder kann
echtes rezept nachmachen
ich muss ich zuerst mal die trockenen
zutaten einmal sieben einfach damit
gleichklang verrühren keine klümpchen
entstehen also puderzucker kakaopulver
und mail einfach 7
angeblich sei es noch die prise salz mit
dazu einfach ein bisschen verrührt das
jetzt alles damit sich alles schön
verbindet wenn sie es nicht schon beim 7
verbunden hat und dann kommt auch
direktes eiweiß betreiben
das muss man auch vorher nicht steif
schlagen dass wir jetzt hier keine pc
masse und vanille extrakt kommt noch mit
rein da können wir jetzt zum beispiel
auch vanillezucker nehmen aber ich nehme
das halt immer gern weil es ein besseres
aroma hat oder weil es intensiver
schmeckt und dann wird es jetzt einfach
verrührt
das ist auch im super rezept was zum
beispiel kinder machen können weil sie
einfach kein werkzeug dafür brauchen wir
müssen einfach alles miteinander
verrühren und es geht einfach super
einfach und total schnell
es fehlen auch mir nochmal genau darauf
wollte ich hinaus
und jetzt ist das ganze sonne ziemlich
klebrige masse sie aber schon richtig
lecker schokolade aus dies ist aus wie
theo und jetzt gehen sie einfach noch
die restlichen zutaten mitteilen man
könnte die mandeln es vorher auch noch
an rösten in der pfanne habe ich jetzt
nicht gemacht aber dadurch wird der
geschmack noch intensiver und die festen
stücke die finde ich super wichtig die
gibt es auch in jedem supermarkt zu
kaufen
denn die sind einfach wichtig weil ich
später nach dem backen dann einfach auch
noch aus so schoko stücke beißt und das
finde ich halt total lecker oder siehst
du das nicht auch so gut ich sehe alles
so wie es aussieht
durch eine rosarote brille und jetzt
nehmt ihr euch einfach einen ice
portionierer oder zum beispiel ein
teelöffel oder was anderes ich habe
zahlten in sehr kleinen als portionierer
ich glaubte hat im durchmesser
zweieinhalb zentimeter und mit dem kann
ich jetzt den teig abstechen und kann
ihn dann direkt auf ein backblech setzen
und da lassen wir uns aber bis platz
zwischen den einzelnen keksen denn die
laufen jetzt gleich noch auseinander
bei mir sind es 24 kekse und die werden
jetzt im ofen bei ober unterhitze 175
grad für etwa neun minuten gebacken
danach werde ich sie komplett abkühlen
lassen und dann zeige ich euch gleich
die fertigen kekse
so sehe jetzt meine fertigen kekse aus
die cookies und ich habs jetzt komplett
abkühlen lassen denn wenn ihr sie zu
früh vom backpapier 100 liter kann sein
dass sie zerbrechen weil es einfach sehr
weich sind
und ich gebe meine jetzt einfach in so
eine keksdose hier zum aufbewahren
das ist übrigens eine die hat so drei
fechter das heißt ihr könnt zum beispiel
drei verschiedene cookies backen und die
dann einfach reinmachen und die
beschriftung ja wenn man sie nicht mag
treten muss einfach weg und wenn man
will dass nur weiß was drin ist kann man
ja das fach fordert eigentlich egal
auf jeden fall ist nur ganz wichtig dass
er wisse dass es keine transportbox ist
als ihr dürft nicht oben nehmen und das
ganze transportieren wollen es hat
nämlich auch schon mal jemand gemacht
dass ich einfach nur eine
aufbewahrungsbox und ich habe hier noch
zwei kekse übrig die anderen hat der
morath schon verschlungen
und zwar habe ich hier auch marshmallows
mit drauf gegeben als so kleine mini
marshmallows bzw ich hatte nur große da
und die habe ich dann einfach
zerschnitten und darauf gelegt das finde
ich auch sehr lecker
nur muss man beachten dass marshmallows
danach ziemlich klebrig werden
und was wenn auch lecker morath er
irgendwann noch die idee ja genauso
es gibt ja auch die seelische weiße
schokolade genau die meisten
schokostückchen kann man auch nehmen da
hat man einfach so ein bisschen andere
optik ich würde sagen habe ich probiert
ich habe schon gegessen sind total
lecker ich würde so ein zeigt euch
einfach mal im innern wie die aussehen
wie sieht man jetzt zum beispiel gleich
so ein schokostückchen wir sind so
richtig schön richtig schokolade
schokolade richtig lecker total gut
ich werde jetzt meine einfach hier so
ein bisschen platzieren dass ich gleich
noch ein foto für euch schießen kann und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
es ist wirklich ein sehr schnelles und
sehr einfaches rezept solltet ihr auf
jeden fall mal ausprobieren
das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf
sallys - blog.de und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder ciao